foreign
[Music]
I lost the button for a second I was
like wait where is it oh okay I'm super
organized as you can tell before the
show starts me and Jenna talk about
other kind of [__] bad [__] I threw
the radar the radio the dish away from
HughesNet the [__] radar dish yeah
because we put a roof on there and the
roofers [__] took the radar or that
[__] dish and threw it down on the
ground
and I threw that [__] out
now HughesNet we had to cancel to use
the net some [__] stupid ass internet
service
and they want the end of that dish it's
got a 200 transmitter in it I threw that
[__] out yeah so they're gonna charge me
200 man well they already charged me
160k early cancellation yeah but that's
better than a 400 cancellation fee yeah
so yeah it's better than paying 100
every month for [__] that we don't use
yeah that's what it is it's trying to
get out of me at the [__] 100
internet bill you know that we don't
even use that internet yeah so we were
talking about that and I was talking
about how it took an hour and a half for
me to get to work this morning because
uh an older woman got run over yeah on
us 92 and they blocked both lanes so I
didn't know that until later like I just
knew that there was I thought there was
just a wreck but yeah a woman got run
over and killed so that's pretty [__]
up so that's how my morning went
and there was something else I was
thinking about and I forgot what it was
you'll think of it in a second I'm sure
you'll probably think of it right when
I'm talking about something else and
then you'll be like I just thought of it
and then I was looking at those piercing
kits on [__] Amazon that's what it
was oh
that's what it was yeah
here's some other [__] that I was
looking at too but
I forgot what it was oh is it you can't
say it on a family show probably can't
say it on a family show I mean like this
is a family show yeah right it's really
not
so if you're if your kids are watching
this then yeah you know that's on you so
it's another haunting Monday yes it is
and uh on Monday we always talk about
the the uh one of the [__] episodes
of The Haunting series which is a
classic series now
and today this is the attic right yes
yeah Daddy I could have sworn we had
done this one already but I think I
think we watched it yeah well no we
watched it and then for whatever reason
we didn't end up doing like we ended up
watching another episode and like doing
that one instead it's the one about a
haunted house
and the woman took a picture and in the
picture she could see like somebody
standing next to her at the sink
like smoking a cigarette a screaming
face on the on the other side they don't
show you the real photograph but they
show you like a reenactment of the
photograph which always makes me kind of
skeptical because if the evidence is
good they'll show it you know
Paranormal Witness they'll show the
evidence that they had uh but that
series probably sucks now too but the
first season of Paranormal Witness was
pretty good
um but this is a good episode this is a
pretty good episode yeah I don't know
why we didn't do it at the time because
I do remember watching it fairly
recently and then I think I guess we
just went to the next episode and was
like oh let's just do this one instead
and then we just never ended up doing it
because I looked up on our thing and we
haven't done this one now they're there
there might be some confusion because
there is actually another episode that's
called nightmare in the Attic or Monster
or Monster In The Attic yeah like
something in the attic I don't know some
[__] up [__] in the Attic
um and we did do that episode but we
didn't do this one which is just called
The Attic yeah darkness in the Attic
monster in the Attic monster in the
basement
all the [__] names these episodes
it's like they just pulled them out of
their head they're a generator you could
probably make a [__] computer
algorithm that would just generate there
has to be one so I feel like somebody
has made one somewhere ghost follows
[Laughter]
I like ghost followers
okay uh Julian Pope said I feel that we
had done this one too because I remember
the dresser being put in front of the
attic door yeah see that's what I
thought but when I looked it up
I mean when I looked it up on our
Channel like I didn't see it in there
anywhere I saw I saw the monster in the
Attic one but not this one it's just uh
it was probably a long time ago
probably the old format
no it wasn't even that because I put all
you know all the shows that we did like
when we did Regular episodes about
haunting cases I put all of those in the
haunting Mondays playlist too
so and I wrote down like all the
episodes we had done before and I could
assume we did this one but I guess not I
know we watched it but we didn't do it
um but yeah so this is actually season
three episode two
and this took place in Spring of 2000 in
Michigan although they don't say where
in Michigan I don't think I think they
just said Michigan like they didn't I
don't remember yeah yeah because if they
had said the city name I would have
written it down so they obviously didn't
say it because I didn't write it down
uh so yeah so the main lady like at the
center of this is named Selena Warner
and the actress that's playing her looks
a lot like I've seen she's been on other
episodes too but she looks a lot like
our friend Amani so like every time I
see her I'm like Hey look it's Imani it
really does look look exactly like her
uh but yeah so that's what I thought I
can't remember what other episode she
was in but she's been some other [__] as
well
but yeah so at the beginning of this one
um
wait a minute oh okay did you lose your
place no no um I was just like looking
at the at the comments see if anybody
said anything
so okay so at the very beginning of this
in 2000
Selena has left her husband presumably
and is you know going off to make a
fresh start buying her own house and all
this other kind of stuff
um so she buys this house near her
sister whose name is Adrian
and she also has a three-year-old son
named Gabe and I guess Grandma also kind
of lives nearby so she kind of takes
Gabe over there to stay with Grandma
like while they're moving into the house
so he's not underfoot I guess
so they go in
Abe's room right that has the door to
the attic right it's like I think
because it's like he has a bathroom in
there and then there's like a little
cul-de-sac type thing with like a door
to the attic again I wasn't keeping
track all the little details yeah I'm
pretty sure that that's what it was
uh is the woman in the story related to
the ghost hunting Warrens no no her last
name's Warner not Warren
but you know
uh uh so yeah so that's where the door
to the attic was now Selena apparently
they don't go super super into this but
apparently she has like a phobia about
addicts all it said was that she slept
in at it in an attic room like as a
child and I guess it was like creepy or
scary or something bad happened to her
in there so it's like she really doesn't
like addicts and they like kind of freak
her out right
so
um so she doesn't really want to you
know kind of go up there and like Show
Adrian the attic but they go up there
anyway because she wants to see it and
then they go up there and apparently
Selena gets like a really really
terrible like headache like as soon as
she's up there she said that it felt
like her head was filled with fog that's
what the real lady said
and so she's basically like yeah I gotta
get the [__] out of here so she goes
back down the stairs and then she said
the headache went away like as soon as
they got back downstairs like as soon as
they got out of the attic
so she's like okay well Ray we're gonna
put a dresser in front of this door
because it's like I don't really want
Gabe going up there because like I said
it's his room and you don't want a
three-year-old kid like wandering around
up on the stairs or whatever like that
so she's puts the [__] thing in front
of the door although I don't know it
kind of bugged me because I was like
I guess because the dresser was just
kind of like short and it's just like I
was like that looks so tacky oops you
know what I mean I don't know why it's
like if you don't want if you don't want
anybody to go in that just take the knob
off and put like a big dresser in front
of it so nobody even knows there's a
door there I kind of feel like that was
I mean if you don't need to go up there
for anything
yeah I remember that I remember that
seeing you yeah yeah
um so basically they're talking about
okay so Adrian the sister who she
doesn't live there she but she lives in
the neighborhood
and um Selena's like well she's kind of
like the artistic or creative person so
I was just gonna let her do the decor or
whatever now said Decor in this case uh
pretty much comprises like uh it looked
like one of those fake garlands
like you get at Michael's or something
like that something you did for
Christmas to go over your house yeah
sorta except it didn't look super
Christmasy but it kind of looked like
Ivy but then with like purple flowers on
it or something and like they kind of
like strung it like and I just thought
that was kind of weird I was like that's
like a weird
it wouldn't it's not weird to like hang
it like Christmas time but it seems like
a weird thing to be there all the time
but maybe that was a 2000 thing yeah 90s
I don't really 90s yeah it's like let's
hang some like fake play it's all over
this I don't know it'd look really
bizarre so uh so Adrian puts that up
there
and uh later that day I guess they both
of them go to the store or wherever and
then they come back from the store and
the Garland is like hanging off of there
and Selena's just like oh well maybe it
just broke or something like that but
Adrian like looked at it it's like it
looks somebody looked like somebody cut
it and I was like well clearly the ghost
doesn't like your decorating skills like
any more than I do so that's that's
something the ghost like cut it down I
guess
so that night
um since everything's kind of like
sorted out and moved in and everything
like that um they go and pick up Gabe
from Grandma's house
now the whole plan is going to be Selena
has to work during the day obviously
like most people do and uh so Adrian is
going to come over during the day and
like stay in the house and babysit him
you know what I mean so that's like a
good setup that they have going I'm
presuming that Selena is paying her to
do this like she's not doing it for free
they didn't really say that but I just
presume so um basically what happens
then like later on I guess like that
night
Gabe starts to get like upset and he's
kind of like calling for his mom and
everything like that like when he's in
his room and she's asking him like you
know what the hell is matter with you
kid and he's like I don't like it here
because it's scary
but she couldn't she said I couldn't
really get him to tell me like what
exactly was scary or what he was scared
of like in particular like I said he's
three so
I'm assuming he's not like super
articulate so like you know why like
what it was that he was afraid man but
yeah he was just basically like it's
scary it's scary so mom's just like what
are you watching him yeah I guess so
yeah I got that another feeling
yeah but but you know a three-year-old
kid can't really articulate like that
they're just like it's scary it's scary
you know what I mean so that's all he
says
so Adrian the sister she comes over the
next day to watch Gabe so Gabe is
napping like three-year-old kids do and
uh Adrian's like just like laying on the
couch reading a book or something like
that and she starts to hear like
creaking like somebody walking around
like on the floorboards or whatever
and so she's like what the [__] is that
so she like gets up and she goes in the
kitchen because that seems to be where
the noise is coming from and she kind of
walks into the kitchen and the cabinet
door is like open just a teeny bit and
then it opens wide like by itself like
while she's looking at it apparently
and I mean I'm presuming that that's
really what she saw because the real
lady was on there and she was like that
[__] freaked her the [__] out which
it would I guess and she said that she
absolutely knew that there was somebody
in there and that they were watching her
like she's checking the door and
everything like that there's obviously
nobody in there but
um you know she said it felt like it
felt like somebody was watching her
so when Selena comes home from work like
later that day Adrian like immediately
tells her it's like um yeah there's like
some really weird chick I went on to
your house um you know I feel like I'm
being watched cabinet doors opening [__]
like that Selena just kind of like
shrugs it off like oh you know whatever
it's probably nothing that's what they
all say at the beginning
but then that night or I don't know if
it was that night or if it was some
night later they didn't really specify
um Selena also hears the same noise like
the same creaking noise like somebody's
walking around
and then she when she hears the creaking
and then she like turns around and that
[__] Garland is like hangs like
broken again like hanging right in front
of her face even though it was fine like
a second before
and then the uh kitchen tap comes on by
itself yeah uh so you know and she's
like wigging the [__] out she's like
yeah I don't like that uh in my notes I
wrote she runs upstairs to check on Gabe
and he's gone but psych he was in the
can so well there's no it was because
that was like a jump scare you know what
I mean like she goes up there and she's
like oh my God the man's empty blah blah
blah and then the kid just came out of
the bathroom like Mom I was just taking
a leak would you [__] chill out you
know you know what I mean it's like yeah
the kid does go to the bathroom
sometimes but yeah he was just in the
cat
so the next morning uh when Adrian comes
over to babysit uh Selena immediately
just tells Adrian she's like um yeah I
think I want to move out so I mean this
is literally I don't even know how long
they've been there it's probably only
been like a couple of days or something
but seriously she just has the tap come
on and the Garland do that [__] and hear
some creaking and she's like yeah about
I don't really want to deal with this
right now she's like I wanna move out
um but Adrian she said that she was
actually kind of more Curious than
scared and she's like maybe what we
should do is we should buy one of those
you know they're like those they used to
have those disposable cameras because
this was his 2000 like before everybody
had digital although a lot of people had
digital cameras but they for some reason
they went and got those throwaway
cameras I can't look at weddings and
[__] like that that are like cardboard
outside
and they got one of those and Adrian's
like you know I read somewhere that you
can go all around the house and like if
you feel like some weird [__] like you
think somebody's there like and you take
a picture like maybe you'll be able to
see them in the picture so that's kind
of like the idea that they're going with
so um Celine is like uh all right
whatever so Adrian goes into the kitchen
and she's like standing by the sink and
then she's like Selena Selena she's like
take a picture take a picture she's like
because there's somebody standing right
beside me like I can feel him standing
right beside me so Selena takes a
picture
and then later on they kind of go all
around the house taking pictures at
various places and then they go up to
the attic and Selena gets that terrible
headache again and then they show her
taking pictures in the attic and then
there's like a Flash and she sees kind
of like a face but she didn't say she
saw that so I think that was like some
[__] right there yeah like they were
trying to make the episode yeah like
they were trying to make it more
exciting yeah because there's a Flash
and it's like oh like you know what I
mean like a monster face or whatever and
but she didn't say anything about seeing
that or she didn't even really react to
it like the actress didn't even like
react to it on the show just like oh
[__] oh my head hurts or whatever and
then she like leaves the attic it's like
you know what I mean it was just kind of
like I don't know I don't know
so uh so the next night Selena has you
know gone to back in the old days when
you used to have to take your pictures
to be developed like kids here being
like what does that mean what's a photo
Matt what are you talking about yeah you
had to like go and pick them up they had
to be printed out on photo paper so she
goes it like Picks Them Up
and one of them the one that she took of
Adrian when Adrian was like standing by
the kitchen sink saying hey there's
somebody right next to me there was very
clearly at least in the fake photo that
they showed on the show I don't know
what the real photo looked like I'm sure
it probably wasn't quite as impressive
but there was very clearly like a
silhouette or like a sort of transparent
dude like standing next to like you
could see his silhouette like in the
window like on the curtain or whatever
and he was just like standing there
smoking a cigarette
uh one of the other photos also had kind
of like a screamy like ghosty skull kind
of face going on it was what is it on
like curtain or something like that or
like on a wall I don't remember no it's
on the other side wouldn't it on the
other side of the woman or maybe oh
that's right yeah another photo yeah
yeah yeah because the one with the
screamy ghosty face didn't have didn't
have any person in it it just had that
face in it but like I said that was just
the one that they showed on the show
yeah they didn't show what the original
photo looked like there's Pokey yeah
you'd been sleeping downstairs all day
you didn't even come up to see me she's
mad she doesn't care yeah she doesn't
care whatever I do whatever yeah
but yeah so at this point I mean they
see the photos hey look Pokemon to show
she's like oh here we go
well she doesn't like being in a lap
yeah because you're like she's like well
I like to just move around on my own
volition I don't like to be like carded
around anymore yeah you know what I mean
she's relaxing though yeah oh
so yeah so they see these pictures with
like the ghost in it it's like it's like
holy [__] like you know obviously
there's ghosts in my house what the [__]
are we gonna do
um Adrian's like well you know I'll help
you out
so the first thing they decide that
they're gonna do
is they're gonna go around to the
neighbors and ask them if they know
anything about the house like if there'd
been like weird [__] happening there
before perhaps
now they find one woman who lives next
door and she tells them she's like oh
didn't anybody tell you and it's like
that's always bad when they start out
with that they didn't tell you oh they
didn't tell you about that oh [__] I'm
not sure if I should tell you but yeah
so this woman says oh yeah um the guy
that lived there before died in that
house like of a drug overdose
and she said matter of fact uh his
family like his wife and daughter still
live in the neighborhood like they live
down they it's a different house
obviously but they lived like down at
the End of the Street
so um so Selena and Adrian go to visit
the family which like I said this I
don't know if I would actually have the
balls to even if I had a picture of what
I thought was a ghost that looked like a
person and they said hey that you know
that ghost's family like lives down the
street I don't know if I'd have the
balls to go to that person's house and
be like hey is this your relative like
that's kind of [__] up yeah so I think
it's kind of funny that they did but
they did exactly that they go to the
house they're like this is gonna sound
kind of weird but
um I moved into your old house and I'm
gonna show you this picture right
because it's the daughter that answered
the door so the daughter answers the
door and they show her the picture and
she's like where the [__] did you get
this she's like that's my dad and um
they're like yeah that's what we figured
um you know what I mean and but to her
credit like the daughter seemed pretty
cool with it she's like yeah he died of
a drug overdue drug overdose and she's
like and I feel really bad because we
had a really bad argument like right
before like you know a few hours where
he died like I told him I hated him and
I never wanted to see him again and he's
ruining our lives and blah blah blah and
then like later on that night like he
killed himself and she's like so I feel
really bad because you know we ended it
like that and maybe that's why he's
still in the house because he has like
all these unresolved issues or whatever
but she does tell them because they said
there was some creepy [__] like going on
in the house and she's like yeah but
she's like even though my dad was like a
drug addict and that was [__] up she's
like but he was a good dude it's like he
wouldn't like hurt anybody or nothing
like that so if anybody if any bad [__]
is having your house just like I don't
think it's him
so then
um the the mom or like the wife of the
of the dead guy I called him crack dad
in my notes I know that's not very uh
that's not very nice but that was just
like I was trying to write fast and that
was just like I knew that that was like
what I I know what I was referring to so
uh so crackdad's wife
comes out and it's like that's act the
same actress that was um
[__] she was just in another episode
that we did she's been in a couple of
episodes too like the woman that played
the wave she seemed a little pissier
about the whole situation
but um you know she's like but she also
like saw the photo and was like yeah
that's definitely him and she said
that's really weird because that's where
he always used to stand she's like every
evening like after dinner I would be at
the sink like doing dishes and he would
stand there next to me and smoke a
cigarette and like we would talk and
stuff like that so it's like it's really
weird that that's where you captured him
like in the photo but like I said she
seemed to get like really upset and
she's like yeah I don't want to talk
about this anymore
so um Selena and Adrian are like well
you know we learned some information
today so that was nice and uh she's like
well they felt a little bit better
because of what the daughter said about
the debt about crackdad that he's like
you know even though he was a crackhead
like he wouldn't hurt anybody and
they're like okay well obviously
whatever is going on in the house like
bad [__] it's not him
so they said that after that happened
um the house was actually pretty calm
for a few weeks
um you know and there's like nothing
weird happened at all and they thought
it was like stopped or whatever
and then uh Selena comes home and
Adrian's like check out this weird ass
drawing that your kid did and it's like
a it was like a man but it had like
instead of a face he had like a bit like
a black scribble type of [__] you know
what I mean like all it's one of those
freaky like you see in horror movies
and uh then like while they're looking
at the drawing being like huh well
that's disturbing
then Gabe yells for his mom again like
he starts like yelling from upstairs
where he's sleeping and when they get up
there they said he was just laying at
his bed kind of like staring up at the
ceiling like all blankly and he was kind
of like feverish
she said Selena said it seemed like he
was possessed I'm not sure exactly what
she meant by that in the reenactment he
was basically just well hey he was
basically just kind of laying there real
stiff like staring up at nothing and
like kind of shaking or like freaking
out like he was I don't know like having
a seizure or something but it was kind
of like that
so um they kind of freak out as you
would and they took him to the ER
now the doctor there examined him and
said Well he seems physically fine but
maybe
um this is psychological you know
because of the divorce and all that kind
of stuff it's like maybe you know it's
hard on kids that age and maybe he
doesn't know how to express it and so
it's just coming out in these weird ways
like that
um but Selena is kind of like I kind of
think it's probably the ghost doing it
like giving him all these night terrors
and [__]
so she decides that she's going to
essentially like just buy a bunch of
religious crap and like put it all over
the house and you know I said haven't
you seen an episode of the show ever
that always that just makes him mad you
know she hasn't seen any episodes of the
show I guess because she just putting
the [__] all over the place so if she's
got Jesus pictures and prayer [__] and
angels and everything just all over the
place
bless you he's back there sneezing
all right
I guess it's dusty yeah but uh all her
little toys are dusty
so uh so yeah so she puts the stuff up
all over the house now later on that
night I guess Selena and Gabe like Gabe
is sleeping in the bed with her
and while they're sleeping she has these
really ugly like tacky like those
praying hands things that are made of
ceramic except they were purple weren't
they they look like they were homemade
too they did and I was like why purple I
don't know I wonder that's like an odd
Choice yeah it kind of looked like a kid
made him like an art classes or
something maybe somebody's Kid Likes a
member of the crew like made about the
show they're like we're gonna break this
[__] though that's what you know spoiler
alert but um but yeah so the praying
hands that are on the nightstand or
whatever they go like two like flying
across the room right into like smash
into a million pieces and then while uh
Selena is like waking up dealing with
that processing that information then I
guess like a picture of Jesus it'll just
kind of look like it just fell off the
wall it didn't really fly off the wall
but still I mean that's still pretty
weird
so at this point Selena just like picks
Gabe out of the bed and is like and they
just get the [__] out the house
so she takes Gabe to Grandma's house
while they are trying to like sort all
this [__] out
so Adrian thinks that she can maybe
um get rid of whatever it is that's in
this house by going around rebuking
she's gonna she's got like [__] she's
got the Bible she's got the [__] and
she's going around like from room to
room like you know rebuking all the you
know telling them to get out
um and in the notes I put creaking and
other noises while she's rebuking that's
what I put sick you know what I mean
there's all kind of noises down
now she actually was going to go up in
the attic and rebuke some [__] up there
but apparently as soon as she opened the
attic door she said she got a really
really bad feeling like if I go up there
like something really really bad is
going to happen so she didn't rebuke
anybody up there
so at this point they are kind of like
they're kind of like going through all
these options because they don't really
know what to do right so they go to this
psychic guy
you know in town or whatever
but as a I guess they decide they're
gonna test him
so they said when we went there we
didn't tell them we were going there
because of like some ghost [__] we told
him that um well Selena told him it's
like oh well I just broke up with my
husband I want to know like if we'll get
back together that's what she told the
guy so she pretended that she was going
there for like relationship advice
that's what she said
um but the psychic
apparently was really psychic because he
did not fall for that that is not why
you were here he says
um he's like there's ghosts in your
house and she's like whoa [__] how the
[__] do you know that dude your friend
told me okay
that's probably what it was well yeah
she said you're coming here
but I'm not going to tell I'm not gonna
tell you that because now it looks like
you have like [__] magical powers and
[__] like my mind I can read my mind
[Laughter]
yeah murder Hornet said should go in
there dressed up like Jesus rebuking it
yeah you never seen on that do you I
wonder if that
if that was cosplay yeah yeah that might
work I kind of yeah I kind of think it's
like a big heart on the front right the
Rays coming up see that'd be badass yeah
Dean could go around like [__] you
could rebuke [__] I'll dress you up like
Mary
a little baby
definitely wouldn't be the Virgin Mary
though just married and we kept and
Pookie could be the baby baby
yeah
you're out there [__] throwing holy
water and confetti and [__]
be gone like Rip Taylor yeah exactly
oh my god oh
flame in your ass
again probably younger people like they
don't know who the [__] are you today
was the gayest man to have ever lived
well I don't know about that in a world
where Paul Lind exists yeah that's true
yeah yeah
Paul Lynd was a totally different cut
from a totally different cloth that's
true [__] Rip Taylor was like the
ultimate [__] 60 he was like 19 and
he was probably about 60 years old yeah
he was really famous big old [__]
mustache and curly head mod very VOD
villain oh yeah and he was just
gay enough to crack the the belt of the
Earth
yeah yeah Thor would have been impressed
yeah he was just real he was on a lot of
those panel shows yeah Hollywood Squares
and stuff like that that was kind of his
shtick was he was always like throwing
confetti and glitter and it's the
ultimate old Queen yeah
Zach said only reason I know about Rip
Taylor is because he was on an episode
of George Lopez it was funny okay so he
just says Zach doesn't know who he is I
just kind of feel like I'm I'm getting
to and it'll it'll happen to you too
like if you're if you're not that old
but you get to a point too where
you're uh you're making references and
stuff like that and then you have people
just looking blankly at you yeah no that
that whole [__] scene was when we
were little kids yeah off a television
yeah game shows well and they were old
when we were they were cold so they were
like old then yeah so that was kind of
like almost like our parents are
grandparents and game shows were
basically live on television if you
lived in California and they were
drinking on the game shows like
Hollywood Squares if you could see him
[__] raising their glasses and
drinking and [__] going
it was television was daytime television
was good back then
because everyone was hammering they were
[__] hammering yeah because they
record them all in [__] they record
them in batches I guess and I guess
they'd be in there all day drinking and
[__] they'd be [__]
slammed yeah yeah
one of the funny things that I was
thinking of when I was uh just thinking
about
um making references that younger people
don't get
um when I was at work they're the girl
that I replaced was real real young and
like also like the other guy that like
Works in my department is also like
pretty young and this other woman that
works in accounting who's a little bit
older than me I think she said she was
55.
but she said that one day she said
something about the the Big Mac song you
know to all be Penny Special Sauce
lettuce cheese blah blah blah
um and she said something about that and
both of the the kids she calls them the
kids in the graphic design department
just looked at her like they had no idea
what she they thought she had lost her
mind yeah she's like the Big Mac jingle
you know they didn't know where she was
talking about and I said well I remember
it
but yeah so
that's just but like I said it'll happen
to you too you'll be like if you were
born in the 90s or the 2000s you'll be
like referring to something from back
then and like people they'll just look
at you like what are you talking about
old person but uh but yeah so back to
the psychic so the psychic whether or
not we don't know who told them like
about the ghosts and everything but he
knew about it apparently but he says now
to his credit he did say that he's like
well I don't have the power to do that
because you think that you know most
psychics would be like oh I could get
rid of that problem for you if you like
you know hand over some [__] money
but he apparently did not say that he
said I don't really have the power to
get rid of uh Spirits that's not really
it's about my pay grade I guess and he's
like well why don't you go to the church
for help
um but that doesn't go too well because
I guess Selena she's I guess she wasn't
like super religious or anything so
she's basically like calling all the
churches in town being like hey you want
to come over and bless my house and no
one was available I'm like really no one
was available
what the [__] else are they doing
nothing that's what so it's like I don't
really know why they couldn't spare
somebody to come over there for an hour
but whatever I just it probably wouldn't
help to probably just made it mad made
the ghost mad because it always does but
uh yeah so she says she can't get any of
the useless [__] out there to bless
the house so they decide that they're
gonna call this kind of local paranormal
investigation group that they had heard
interviewed on the radio and this was
actually the southeast Michigan Ghost
Hunter Society I don't know if they're
still around or not
they said that it was I think their
names were I'm assuming it's a married
couple
or it might be brother and sister I'm
not sure they have the same last name so
I'm not really sure but um I think they
said the woman's name was Brenda and the
guy's name is Brad and I think they said
their last name was makulka that was
something like that I couldn't really
hear it that good but it sounded like
makulka
so the two of them come to do an
investigation uh they also have a team
psychic team psychic uh whose name was
Mary something I didn't catch the last
name malka milka something like that
because like I said I can't hear all
that good and I'm trying to like write
down stuff really fast and the first for
whatever reason I think we've mentioned
this before because I usually I always
almost always have when I'm watching
something I always have closed
captioning on because like I said I'm
deaf as [__] and I can't really tell
what people are saying so um but for
whatever reason our haunting discs don't
have closed captioning
so yeah that's weird that's really weird
so I guess like the production company
was like [__] the deaf yeah I'm like
that's nice
they didn't want to spend extra money to
get to get the captions on there I guess
not nowadays they just use AI yeah and I
mean it's not great the AI because you
know our YouTube videos after a while
like it generates its own yeah
um captions captions and it's okay but
like some of the shit's not good but
especially like proper names and stuff
which you know that makes sense that it
wouldn't know that
but yeah
so the psychic she uh comes in the house
and was apparently drawn to the attic I
don't know if they told her beforehand
that's where all the shenanigans were
happening but whatever
and basically she tells them that
whatever entity this is in the Attic is
like sucking everyone's energy out like
they do and basically also wanted
everything yeah
energy
[Laughter]
what's this gonna cost me
foreign
yeah but uh well the weird thing about
it is that he seemed to be like sucking
any energy from everybody but then the
psychic said to you that he wanted
everyone out the house because they were
like intruding and I was like well you
think he'd want people in there like for
more energy suckage but you know you
know what I mean but I guess we're gonna
get you on some energy stuff
that's going up on the only fans
energy suckage energy suck Zach said
also I love attic bedrooms because of
the weird roof lines yeah me too so I
don't know what what her face was
complaining about I would have dug that
as a kid yeah me too I always kind of
wish I never lived in a house with an
attic
but um you know not a real addict that
you could like have a room in but we
just have like attic crawl spaces like
everywhere we've lived recently but I
was always like I'd see that in movies
sometimes I'd be like man that's so cool
like that [__] well wait well the
room in Amityville like with the scary
windows that wasn't really the attic was
it no it wasn't inadequate I don't think
it was somebody's bedroom well no no but
I mean an addict can be somebody's
bedroom too like you can sleep in the
Attic bedroom that's what we were
talking about but I was just saying in
the Amityville house that wasn't
technically it wasn't an addict no it
was just a top bedroom
yeah but I do like those um but some
houses do have like addicts that have
been converted into bedrooms and they
have like those slanted roofs and stuff
I like that but I hadn't seen the movie
in a long time but I think it was just a
top it's just a bedroom up there
I don't think it was an attic at all
Melissa is laughing I totally remember
that Tom and Jenny oh my God telling my
age now I don't know what like Rip
Taylor or was it or the Big Mac song
no contacts people
Crowley says one of my friends uh had a
door to the attic in his bedroom yeah
that was the situation in this house too
apparently like the little
three-year-old kid had the door to the
attic in his bedroom
so uh so yeah the paranormal team they
put a motion detector thing like in a
camera like up in the attic because like
I said that's kind of where a lot of the
activity was going on
now in the basement uh the psychic
senses crackdad
um
the ghost that I call cracked at like I
said I know that's mean but that's just
like what I call them in the notes and
um she knows that this isn't the Ghost
that's causing the problems because
she's like I didn't sense any hostility
from this particular ghost he was just
sad
um and apparently she figured out that
he wanted to kind of like make good with
his family before he crossed over like
he wanted to you know see if they
forgave him or whatever because he'd
killed himself and like [__] him over
so um while Selena and Adrian are being
interviewed
by one member of the paranormal team the
attic motion detector goes off uh you
know when nobody's up there so they go
up there and they look at the footage
and it's basically just orbs
I mean they showed the the thing like it
looked kind of impressive on the show
but I'm sure that's probably not what it
really was it was probably just like a
couple dust moats in front of the [__]
yeah orbs are always dust every ore or
bugs yeah or a bug
I yeah I've never really seen any
pictures of orbs so it's like I don't
even know why that's a thing well yeah I
know why it's a thing but I'm just
saying it's it shouldn't be a thing
because dust in front of the camera
pretty much yeah
that's what it always is I've never seen
one that wasn't that
so uh so yeah so there's kind of orbs
and it's like these ghosty kind of
things going around there just like wow
that's awesome blah blah blah and then
like Selena
um her head
starts hurting again like it always does
like when she's in the attic I guess
that's the energy suckage causing her to
have like a migraine or whatever
now after several hours that the team is
there they have determined that I mean
duh that there are two Spirits which you
know they pretty much figured out anyway
there's like there's crack dad down in
the basement who's the sad one and then
there's like the [__] one that's up
in the attic who who knows who the [__]
that dude is they never said that the
they never said that the entity or
whatever it was in the Attic was like a
person but they didn't also they also
didn't say it was a demon which is nice
that was refreshing because I kind of
feel like they're always
are like a jump into well there's a
ghost in the house but he's nice but oh
but then there's this other one that's
demonic you know what I mean but I don't
think they said demonic on this one
I think they just said that it was like
an entity or like a darker inner like I
don't know it was just like another
ghost and he's a jerk
so um Selena basically is like well
you know the nice ghost can stay if he
wants to but uh that attic [__] has
really gotta go like I I can't like live
in the same house with that dude
so the team is just kind of like well
basically what we think is that uh the
attic ghost is just real Territorial
and maybe if you just like stay out of
the attic like stay out of his you know
territory then maybe he'll leave you
alone although that really doesn't seem
to be working thus far because as far as
I know they had been staying out of the
attic like by and large and he was still
like [__] with them so I don't really
know whatever
um but yeah they're like well if you
stay out of his way like he might not
[__] with you
so uh at this point they send like the
three-year-old kid up back to Grandma's
again uh until all of this [__] gets
sorted out
now at this point which I thought was
kind of weird so the daughter of
crackdad who had used to live in this
house right she just like shows up
unexpected she doesn't call or nothing
which you know that's a little bit rude
but she shows up and she with us with
another psychic or a spiritualist or
something she shows up at the door and
she's like I'm sorry to just bursting on
you like this but you know I want to
come in here and like talk to my dad's
ghost basically she's like I want to
like tell him I forgive him and blah
blah and maybe that will help him move
on and I was like well you could have
called but okay
so um so they show up
and she goes down and so like Selena and
them are like well maybe if she you know
goes to you know crackdad ghost and like
talks to him and he passes over like
maybe that'll get rid of the [__]
goes to like they're kind of hoping I
don't you know I don't know why it would
but okay
so the spiritualist this was weird
because the spiritualist lady like she
went up to the attic which is not where
the crackdad ghost was he was in the
basement right and she goes up there and
she's got like blessed salt water and
all that and she's like splashing all
that around the attic and she's talking
to crackdad even though she's in the
attic and there was another ghost up
there which I presumably they knew about
I don't really know
but uh so while she's up there she
apparently senses the [__] ghost
instead it's like yeah remember to get
out of here so the daughter goes out to
the basement and you know talks to her
dad or like the ghost of her dad telling
him you know I forgive you and blah blah
so apparently the dad the crack dad goes
like he crossed over
and so the daughter comes up and she's
all happy and everything and she's like
I think he's gone blah blah so Selena
and Adrian said yeah the house felt a
lot better after that like a lot calmer
and less tense and everything so it's
like they presumed that you know he had
been forgiven and he had forgiven them
and he'd gone like over to the other
side or whatever
so after this incident the house they
said was peaceful for a few days
and Selena goes to Grandma's house and
gets Gabe back home because she thinks
it's safe there now because she thinks
that that the [__] addict goes has
also [__] off
but apparently this is not the case
because
Adrian is watching Gabe
and I guess she hears a voice I couldn't
make out what the voice said though I
didn't know if it was like someone's
name or I didn't know what it said but
it sounded like like it said something
like in her ear or something and I was
just like I didn't catch that
um but then Gabe start like the little
kid he starts having like another
episode where he just like goes over on
his back and it's like it's almost like
he was having like an epileptic fit or
like a seizure or something like he was
just laying there like staring at the
ceiling and um kind of like freaking out
and sweating and everything
and so Adrian like runs over to him and
he's like there's nothing there there's
nothing there because he was like
standing up staring at the ceiling and
then like Selena comes home from work
and Adrian's just like holy [__] like
look it's happening again and so
basically at this point this is kind of
an Abrupt ending but they basically are
like all right we're out of here so they
just like picked they just packed up
their [__] and left like and they
apparently did not come back to the
house after that and Selena said that
she's like as soon as I was out of the
house she's like I just felt like an
enormous weight like lifted off my
shoulders or whatever and evidently
they just didn't go back so I guess like
the [__] ghost was still there and
she said like later on like at the end
of the show she said
um I just kind of hope that that [__]
in the Attic like that he's not there
anymore because you know I would hate to
think that he was like [__] with the
people that live there now
but that was pretty much I was like wait
that was it like because it seemed like
it was building up and building up and
then like the kid had another episode
and I thought like some other big thing
was gonna happen or they were going to
do like a big exorcism or something like
they usually do but they didn't I mean
basically they were just kind of like oh
well they just got the [__] out which
like I said it was probably like the
smartest decision and I I kind of wish
more
families would do that
I know that they can't like it's not
practical I mean you know if something
happened like that it's like most people
can't afford to just like up and move
like at the drop of the Hat even if
something's like really bad but I don't
know what to make in this case it wasn't
there there's not a lot of cooperating
evidence you know I mean not a lot of
witnesses really kind of came forward
you know the police weren't called
if it happened is a bad house you know I
guess yeah ghosts
but you know I never really seen
anything like that
I've been in a bad house and I've seen
Poltergeist but they're very difficult
they're very different I told you guys
all about moving stuff
a bad house is about being watched but
nothing really ever moves you can't
really put your finger on it just
something wrong about the police
um
this is kind of a mixture of everything
things are moving they were seeing
apparitions
um getting evidently getting photographs
just that made them think that there
were ghosts in the house although I
would really like to see those yes yeah
when they don't show the actual
photograph I'm always
they're not showing the actual actual
photograph because it's not convincing
they asked me yeah so they probably had
somebody Photoshop like a better one
yeah well that's what they showed yeah
you could tell them
so you know
I don't know not enough information
really to make a
judgment on it maybe it have maybe it
didn't
maybe parts I mean maybe other parts if
it was true that they took pictures in
the house and
the and they went to the neighbor's
house and the neighbor actually
recognized yeah I mean that's pretty
weird but I don't know if that happened
the way that they showed it in the show
did you never know that way you'd think
that they would show the actual photo
that's what I'm saying like yeah if the
photo was clear enough that somebody'd
be like holy [__] that's my dad right
like in you know in ghost form
that's perfect
Zach said I saw some posts on a UFO
subreddit and there are people legit
thinking some [__] up lens flare their
camera was making was one like a UFO I
mean that's the thing if people if they
really want to believe it badly enough
um then
then anything will be that and I think
that's how that whole orb thing started
because it's not like they were going
around getting like these really
Kick-Ass pictures of like apparitions
and [__] like that so you know every now
and then you'd get an orb in front of
the camera like some dust or like a bug
or something or you know you get part of
your thumb in there without realizing it
and you're like look at that it's like a
[__] it's you know it's a it's a
spirit like in the picture Melissa gave
some context on what she was talking
about oh drinking on the games most of
them are on drugs or drunk or both good
times yeah you could tell they were
coked out some of them yeah Charles
Nelson Riley coked out
yeah there's another one I kind of feel
like a lot of them yeah back then and in
between shots you can see them putting
the glass down do they have a [__]
Scotch there and behind it especially
Hollywood Squares Hollywood Squares they
were [__] up
especially towards the end of the week
yeah yeah you can tell they were drunk
because like you said I kind of feel
like they they probably because they
were only like half hour [__] well not
even half hours it's like I think they
were 24 minutes like with commercials
yeah so you could do a whole week's work
so they'd probably do like a whole
week's worth of them in like one session
yeah and they were drinking the whole
time partying and they would [__] they
wouldn't hide the fact that they were
drinking
towards you know well it's been trying
to play it made the show better yeah
well especially something like that but
the thing about Hollywood Squares is
that I don't know
how much of that I mean they made it
seem like a lot of it was improved I
think a lot of it was and I think a lot
of it was but I mean I know that there's
you know TV magic that they can use to
like make it seem like oh they're just
coming up with this stuff on the Fly and
maybe they write it ahead of time but I
don't know a lot of it did seem like it
was improved well
this that Center Square we just named
him [__] what was his name [__] uh
uh Paul in yeah Pauline was the center
he ended up being the center square and
he was just [__] loaded and funny the
whole [__] time
just them calling his name he they
people would start laughing
he was he was he was the best he was the
best
celebrity in the Hollywood Square yeah
that dude was hilarious [__]
hilarious
he was like super [__] and it's like
yeah you can see all that old [__] on
YouTube they got they have those little
game shows they also had the Liars Club
I love the Liars Club yeah it's where
you had comedians and they would give
them a strange object that you couldn't
identify and the comedian would sit
there and lie and tell us some kind of
story of what this object was and the
contestants had to bet who was telling
the truth
you know five of them would be lying one
of them be telling the truth you had to
bet on put money on who was telling the
truth and uh man I had Buddy Hackett on
there they had all the guy from Hogan's
Heroes was on there you know the uh who
Bob Crane the one that got murdered no
the blonde-haired guy oh okay who played
the American pilot I think or the
British pilot I forgot
um but they did have different ones on
there I like that show as a kid Joker's
Wild I [__] love the 70s oh I really
likes Jokers well for some reason yeah I
think I liked it because when I was a
kid it had that scary Joker face and it
was like real into scary [__] well I'm
still into this old Family Feud was fun
with Richard Dawson yeah he'd get drunk
on the [__] show and be grew up in
people's daughters and wives and [__] in
the middle of the [__] show he's a
perv he's a bit rapey
yeah funny bear creepy you could get
away with that kind of [__] he's
obviously [__] toasted towards the
end of the [__] week he's [__]
look he's lit yeah Danny Rowling said
the hot brunette sister in this episode
uh played the psychic and the haunted
barn episode you just did yeah that's
right I thought she looked familiar see
I'm just kind of like I think all of the
actors in This were in other episodes
for sure like she was in the barn one
and then the woman that played Selena
that looks like our friend she was in
some other stuff too and the woman that
played crackdad's wife like or Widow
rather
um she was man she was on one episode
that we just did like
it was that one where there was like
thing well was that one where there was
a thing in the basement where she saw
like the guy like dragging the two girls
down into the basement oh man I can't
remember we just did it a couple weeks
ago like I can't remember which what the
name of it is but she was the mom like
on that one oh
um the guy that was the ghost that was
molesting the daughter right yeah yeah
yeah and they got died in the car right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's yeah that's
it but like we just did that one like a
couple weeks ago that was the same woman
that played crackdad's wife on this one
has anyone watched paranormal 9-1-1 or
paranormal emergency I think that's the
thing I have not seen it uh what was the
one that we started watching was it on
Netflix
what was it called 28 days haunted or I
don't know oh is it like yeah yeah we
started like I like the premise of it we
got like 15 20 minutes but we got like
20 and we're like that seems kind of
boring
it doesn't I don't really like I like
the reenactment ones more than like the
ghost hunter style where it's just like
Taps and [__] right where it's just like
guys sitting around like in in night
vision camera being like did you hear
that you know I'm like I heard that like
no I heard that too I didn't hear
anything I'm like you guys are making
that up
did you guys see that I feel cold yeah
yeah like yeah I'm just like there's
something here
laughs
see that's like not if at least when you
watch like a haunting or Paranormal
Witness at least like they have it's
like a reenactment so you can see so
it's kind of interesting and they try to
keep it interesting those other the
Ghost Hunter ones where they're just
like sitting around waiting for some
[__] to happen and then pretending that
something exciting is going on other
than ghost Brothers I like ghost
Brothers yeah but but I liked it guys a
lot of that was goofing off that's what
I mean but see they were funny and they
were like charismatic yeah and so like I
feel like a lot of the paranormal
investigators aren't really they're not
like entertaining in their own right
whereas ghost Brothers they were just
like funny I would have just watched
them even if they weren't looking for
ghosts I don't know if this program's
still around probably not but it's like
I really like that they were funny as
[__] and make the dude just sit in the
[__] dark room he's like man [__]
this
that's right man
I can't take this
yeah I heard that
yeah it was super funny and they were
always kind of like [__] with each
other like yeah because they knew that
they were all like really scary
[__] they can do the [__] just give
himself scared
yeah they were like psyching themselves
it's like really funny
uh Zach says by the way it looks like
there's a bunch of drama in the
Paranormal Community a bunch of Zack
Baggins former co-hosts are outing him
as a huge douche
um is that really outing him though
because I thought everybody knew that he
was a huge yeah
no no that's that's the Ghost Hunter guy
oh the Ghost Hunter yeah yeah that's
like the OG the other guy was he was he
was [__] stole everybody's money
oh yeah I know who you're talking about
yeah Zach Baggins is the guy that kind
of looks I always want to say Bilbo bag
Zach Bilbo Baggins it's not I know it's
not spelled the same but um he's the guy
that kind of looks like he would be like
in a 90s alt rock band with the spiky
hair and I don't know that one and he's
kind of like buff and I don't know that
one you know what I mean you'd know him
if you saw him okay but yeah that's the
thing it's
I don't I don't know why he would have
to be outed as a douche I was pretty
sure everybody knew he was a douche but
that's just kind of how he comes across
all right so uh you ready to wrap it up
wrap it up okay so uh yeah we're gonna
wrap it up like I said
so thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening and uh our next show is going to
be Wednesday night that's going to be
our main show and I'm sure a lot of
people are excited about this because I
had a lot of people uh recommend this
and it actually won in the poll we are
going to be talking about the
investigative journalist Gary Webb uh
the guy who well he didn't necessarily
uncover it but he kind of like
um
sort of got it out into the public the
whole uh the whole um CIA like when the
crack epidemic thing you know what I
mean funding the contras and all that
okay so uh and then he ended up dying by
Suicide supposedly yeah um so shot in
the back three times and then hung well
well it wasn't quite that bad but um but
yeah there there is some well I don't
know I don't know how much question
there is about like his death but but um
all of the stuff he uncovered like about
all the [__] that was going on in the
80s yeah with uh the CIA funding the
contras and and selling crack and all
this yeah I mean the CIA wasn't selling
crack but you know what I mean they were
indirectly black what's called black
budget fundings
yeah Zach says oh a final fantasy house
didn't win I know we'll we'll get to it
one of these days I keep putting it at
the poll but it like never wins you know
what I mean uh but yeah so that's what
the show is going to be about Wednesday
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that show it should be a good show and
uh yeah hopefully you guys have a good
rest of your evening and we'll see you
guys again on Wednesday